>>> GOT AN UPDATE NOW ON A SRY
WE HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING.
OFFICIALS AT BRIGHAM YOUNG
UNIVERSITY SAY THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE ANY RACIAL HECKLING
HAPPENED DURING A VOLLEYBALL
MATCH AGAINST DUKE UNIVERSITY
LAST MONTH.
BYU INITIALLY APOLOGIZED TO DUKE
AND BANNED A FAN ACCUSED OF
SHOUTING RACIAL SLURS.
CNN'S MARTIN SAVIDGE JOINS US
NOW.
A COUPLE OF BIG REVERSALS.
WHAT IS BYU SAYING?
>> BYU IS BASICALLY SAYING THEY
DID AN INTERNAL REVIEW AND THEY
HAVE FOUND NOTHING, THEY SAY,
THAT CAN CORROBORATE THE CLAIM
BY A DUKE UNIVERSITY ATHLETIC
STUDENT THAT THERE WERE
RACIAL -- THERE WAS RACIAL
HARASSMENT THAT TOOK PLACE.
LET ME JUST SORT OF BACK THIS
UP.
SO IT WAS THE END OF AUGUST WHEN
RACHEL RICHARDSON, WHO IS A
SOPHOMORE STARTER ON THE DUKE
UNIVERSITY VOLLEYBALL TEAM,
TWEETED OUT THAT TWO DAYS PRIOR,
THE DUKE UNIVERSITY TEAM,
ESPECIALLY BLACK MEMBERS OF THAT
TEAM, WERE HECKLED BY A BYU FAN
DURING A GAME THAT WAS BEING
PLAYED IN UTAH.
WHAT'S MORE, SHE WENT ON TO SAY,
THIS WAS RACIAL HECKLING.
THIS WAS HATRED, PURE HATRED
COMING OUT.
ON TOP OF THAT, WHEN THE DUKE
ATHLETIC MEMBERS MADE THIS KNOWN
TO THE BYU PERSONNEL, SPORTS
PERSONNEL, THEY DID NOTHING TO
INTERVENE OR STOP IT IN REAL
TIME.
AND SINCE THAT TIME, THERE'S
BEEN AN INVESTIGATION THAT HAS
BEEN DONE BY BYU, AND THEY SAY
THAT THEY HAVE REVIEWED AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING OF THE GAME
AS WELL AS FROM THE UNIVERSITY
BROADCAST FOOTAGE.
THEY ALSO MAINTAIN THEY TALKED
TO AT LEAST 50 GAME ATTENDEES
THAT INCLUDING DUKE AND BYU
ATHLETIC PERSONNEL AND STUDENT
ATHLETES AND CAME UP WITH THE
FOLLOWING.
FROM OUR EXTENSIVE REVIEW, WE
HAVE NOT FOUND ANY EVIDENCE TO
CORROBORATE THE ALLEGATION THAT
FANS ENGAGED IN RACIAL HECKLING
OR UTTERED RACIAL SLURS AT THE
EVENT.
AS WE STATED EARLIER, WE WOULD
NOT TOLERATE ANY CONDUCT THAT
WOULD MAKE A STUDENT ATHLETE
FEEL UNSAFE.
OKAY, SO THAT WAS BYU.
SHORTLY THEREAFTER, DUKE
UNIVERSITY CAME OUT WITH THEIR
OWN STATEMENT AND THEY SAY THIS
IN RESPONSE.
THE 18 MEMBERS OF THE DUKE
UNIVERSITY VOLLEYBALL TEAM ARE
EXCEPTIONALLY STRONG WOMEN WHO
REPRESENT THEMSELVES, THEIR
FAMILIES, AND DUKE UNIVERSITY
WITH THE UTMOST INTEGRITY.
WE UNEQUIVOCALLY STAND WITH AND
CHAMPION THEM.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEIR CHARACTER
IS CALLED INTO QUESTION.
SO NOT A DIRECT CRITICISM OF BYU
AND THEIR INVESTIGATION.
THEY SIMPLY, DUKE IS SAYING WE
BELIEVE OUR OWN STUDENT ATHLETES
HERE.
IT'S QUITE CLEAR THAT BOTH